ils étaient près de 300 à tenter le défi
c'est trappistes participer à l'euro
dictée ils n'ont pas tous le même but
c'est ce qui me plaît cela c'est gagner
les 25 heures pour tester mes capacités
en orthographe
ça me permettent de dessiner mon niveau
parce que maintenant comme je disais aux
collègues avec les correcteurs
automatiques au travail on fait plus
trop attention à l'orthographe
et on se laisse aller sa dictée sur les
douze ont déjà eu lieu en ile de france
elles sont à l'initiative de la
direction régionale de la jeunesse des
sports et de la cohésion sociale
vive et c'est de sortir la dictée de
l'école et de montrer qu autour d'une
dictée on peut faire à un moment festif
et tous se retrouver quel que soit notre
génération où notre milieu social le
système d'évaluation c'est plutôt ceux
qui font le moins de fautes de manière à
ce qu'on n'ait pas l'impression qu'il y
ait une sanction mais plutôt en
challenge se dire je vais être le
meilleur choix est celui qui fait le
moins de fautes à trappes
ils se sont confrontés à un texte de
victor hugo 93 lui est dicté par la
ministre de l'éducation et utiliser
cette opportunité pour finalement faire
revenir quand même les élèves
les jeunes leurs parents à l'essentiel
c'est à dire la bonne maîtrise de la
langue française et le bonheur que c'est
que en effet de maîtriser ce qu'on écrit
ce qu'on comprend ce qu'on écoute
dix personnes sont repartis avec deux
places pour des matches de l'euro une
finale aura lieu le 10 juin avec
d'autres cadeaux à gagner